what up space fam golden here from anime
opera back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest in the one punch man
story today we got the craziest thing
we've seen in quite a while so make sure
to stay tuned for this one if you do
enjoy seeing these one punch man videos
and want to keep them coming channel
decide them all within and serious punch
that like button remember that smashing
that like button is saitama energy and
passing is fear or ugly energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one punch man videos and updates and
while you wait for the next exciting
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my one punch man playlist that includes
videos on all the s-class heroes all
dragon and god level monsters and more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all for the cover page in
this one we have a very cute tatsumaki
in a library and i love libraries so i'm
a happy camper but on to the chapter
itself and it's called forfeit so
something decisive is going down clearly
we join back to the battle between garo
and bang garo uses exploding heart
versus bangs water stream and it is
intense you can see the veins popping
out on garo's legs which is a very
cinematic panel we're told that the
exploding heart release fist causes once
hard to pulse explosively in time with
the impact of their punches which sounds
dangerous but would obviously increase
the force of the attack bang definitely
doesn't seem to be in good shape against
his former pupil but he's sticking in
there for the time being bang explains
that the exploding heart release fist
allows one in those specific moments to
surpass their body's limits i really
like that detail it's very powerful but
it comes with conditions it's called a
wicked style that brings total
devastation and bang remarks that this
is bad because even though he's
deflecting the hits the shock waves
themselves are adding up thus the damage
is accumulating even if bang is not
getting directly hit which is pretty
crazy powerful we get some epic panels
including bang dodging garo in epic
fashion and then catching him from
behind bomb thinks there's going to be
grappling but bang as if not even trying
to win really uses the situation to
correct the stance of garo his main goal
is clearly trying to break through
tagaro which was already implied not to
stop him at any cost and even though we
all know that garo will win this this
was a pretty big flex on bang's part as
he's giving his opponent pointers in the
middle of the fight bomb also can't help
but be touched by bang's actions towards
his pupil garo goes to kick bang but
bang dodges and lands a hit on garo
which sends him flying he even calls him
a foolish novice i like the fact that
they are giving bang plenty of moments
of being awesome like this even if he
can slash won't win this fight overall
always appreciate the bang respect then
garo does something truly crazy he uses
roaring aura sky ripping fist against
bang the technique that asbang mentioned
he and his brother combined barely
managed to unleash bang is very shocked
wondering if this is possible because of
the monsterization that garu is
undergoing
bomb as the useful commentator from the
side comments that the shock waves are
so powerful that they are turning the
debris into powder it's very intense as
bang can't let one hit land if he does
the shock waves will envelope him and
break every bone in his body this is
great action i must say the attacks
intensify as they face each other head
on and bomb wonders if his brother can
really pull it off bang although an
awesome character throughout has never
been so cool as right now when you see
his determined face and bam at the
decisive moment he lands the hit and
garo doesn't now from a pure technique
standpoint you could argue that garo is
not as technically skilled as bang
however this form of garo is too
powerful and having just grazed bang
bang suddenly feels the after effects he
falls down saying he guesses he couldn't
do it he couldn't be as cool as his
brother bomb when he saved and beat the
bang in the past there is some possible
symbolism here though since garo's
monster exterior starts to crumble where
bang punched it perhaps bang's efforts
were not in vain and he is getting
through togaro bomb is screaming out for
bang while garo shakes holding his face
in his hands clearly affected by what
just transpired then ugly shows up who
was looking for bang after bang
absolutely destroyed his previous
incarnation but before we see what
happens with that we jump to the other
side of the battlefield which is not any
less interesting people are still
looking to see what king is gonna do as
platinum s is finishing his
transformation they attribute the fact
that he's not doing anything to him
being cautious and observing i love the
fact that throughout the series you know
people always find a rationale like this
for king's actions or lack thereof
homeless emperor just seems sad and
ridiculous at this point he can't even
deal with zombie man at this point and
he says that platinum s is unimaginably
powerful but not as powerful as him wow
yeah right dude zombie man thankfully
knows it's all bs and wants to question
homeless emperor he wants to figure out
if it's true how he got his power and if
so they have to learn more about this
god character pulling the strings and
the god character clearly doesn't like
this since he suddenly appears or at
least appears before homeless emperor
the implication is the others can't see
him his abilities are insane he doesn't
want them to find more information out
about him so he says he's taking
homeless emperor's powers back from him
again you can imagine how strong a dude
that can create dragon level threats and
destroy them like their nothing has to
be without even going into the fact that
he's seemingly everywhere at once and
can do whatever he wants although it's
hard to even begin to categorize his
power since he doesn't seem to even
appear in physical form but
psychologically this dude definitely
seems like a greater threat than even
platinum s and if there were ever to be
a god level threat it makes sense that
it should go to so-called god right but
that aside this part is fascinating
murata colored these panels from
homeless emperor's perspective we see
the moon and the figure appear on it and
it is some of the scariest creepiest
illustrations we've seen so far no doubt
so huge props to murata for that you can
see the pure horror in homeless
emperor's face and sweats too i love
zombie man's response here like he's
talking to a bro and trying his concern
but it's no use he can't get through to
homeless emperor who appears in his
psyche or on some different plane in
front of this god figure that towers
over him and honestly me saying towers
over him isn't even doing it justice
he's like an ant compared to this figure
the flesh and skeletal body is again
super creepy which is quite the contrast
to the beautiful meadow and sky in this
dimension he says he'll take back
homeless emperor's powers and life and
he does he specifically says both are
forfeit so the title of the chapter came
from this god character is dialogue
showing that he's meant to be the big
crazy thing this chapter that's
reflected in the uncharacteristically
colored panels as well as homeless is
withering away into nothing he says god
and zombie man is now panicking zombie
man was cool as a cucumber up to this
point but even he who was suspicious
before about this god character can't
deny anymore that there is clearly
something responsible for this it seems
he's becoming more convinced that
someone really granted homeless emperor
his powers and the moon is shown in the
final panel we shall see the
significance between the moon and this
god character it doesn't seem to be a
coincidence to me that he just appeared
on the moon perhaps the moon is somehow
a portal between these planes or like dr
t.j eckleburg's eyes in the grey gatsby
it's there to remind us that god is
always watching let me know what you
think but that is it for this chapter
who was your mvp here i gotta go with
bang although garo just has that insane
raw power bang did so well and i'm so
glad he went down in such an epic way
rather than just being overpowered from
the start if you did enjoy this review
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do channel the saitama within
and serious punch that like button
remember that smashing that like button
aside to my energy and passing is pure
ugly energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one punch man videos and updates
that's just the way it works and while
you wait for the next exciting chapter
to drop feel free to check out my one
punch man playlist that includes videos
on all the s-class heroes all dragon and
god level monsters and more link to that
is in the description and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
my
you